>> Tucker: IT HAS BEEN AN
EXCITING WEEK FOR CNN, RUSSIAN
COLLISION IS STILL A LIE.
BUT THEY FINALLY GOT SOMEONE TO
LEAK INFORMATION ON
DONALD TRUMP'S TAXES FROM 30
YEARS AGO.
THAT INFORMATION SHOW THAT TRUMP
LOST MONEY.
PEOPLE AT THE NETWORK WERE
EXCITED ABOUT THIS.
>> THIS IS CNN TONIGHT AND I DON
THE MEN.
ARE YOU LISTENING?
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS A FRAUD AND A
CON MAN.
YOU ARE SAYING IS A SOCIOPATH?
>> WITHOUT ANY QUESTION.
>> IT WAS A CON, ALL OF IT?
>> THIS PERSON IS A WALKING
FRAUD.
>> HE CALLS PEOPLE LOSERS AND
HAS SUCH DISDAIN BUT HE IS
LITERALLY THE BIGGEST LOSER IN
THE COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: IF YOU REMEMBER THE
90s, YOU MIGHT RECALL THAT
TRUMP'S BUSINESS PROBLEMS OR
REAL NEWS STORY.
THEY WERE REAL, TRUMP WROTE A
BOOK ABOUT THEM.
BUT DON'T TELL DON LeMOND, HE
WAS SHOCKED.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT THEY SAY ABOUT
CASINO GAMBLING, THE HOUSE
ALWAYS WINS.
WELL, NOT ALWAYS.
NOT IF IT IS A TRUMP CASINO.
COME ON IN.
WHO LOSES MONEY AT A CASINO
EXCEPT FOR THE PERSON GAMBLING.
NOT THE OWNER.
BECAUSE I'M GOOD ENOUGH, SMART
ENOUGH, AND DOGGONE IT, PEOPLE
LOVE ME.
[LAUGHS]
>> Tucker: WHAT ARE THE ODDS
THAT HE SAYS THAT EARLY IN THE
MIRROR EVERY MORNING?
JOE CONCHA JOINS US FROM THE
HILL.
SO THIS DIDN'T -- THEY BASICALLY
DISCOVERED THAT TRUMP LOST A TON
OF MONEY IN THE 90s WHICH,
ANYONE WHO IS ALIVE THEN NEW
BECAUSE IT WAS A MAJOR STORY.
BUT THIS WAS NEWS BECAUSE, WHY?
>> IT WAS PRESENTED AS A
RECYCLED NEWS.
I DON'T LIKE TO USE THE TERM
FAKE NEWS, TUCKER BUT IN THIS
CASE YOU COULD HAVE READ
DONALD TRUMP'S BOOK FROM 2007,
THE ART OF THE COMEBACK.
YOU COULD HAVE READ ANY OF THE
NEW YORK TABLOIDS.
"THE NEW YORK POST" AND
"NEW YORK DAILY NEWS" TALKED
ABOUT THE TRUMP SLUMP.
YOU COULD HAVE WATCHED THEIR
APPRENTICE, SEASON ONE EPISODE
ONE, THE VERY FIRST SEGMENT.
DONALD TRUMP LITERALLY SAYS ON
VIDEO THAT HE LOST BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
HE WAS BILLIONS IN DEBT AND HE
WAS ABLE TO COME BACK.
SO TO KEEP ALL OF THAT OUT OF
REPORTING, IF WE WANT TO CALL
THIS EVEN REPORTING, THIS WAS
THE BIAS OF OMISSION AND THAT
WAS THE WORST KIND OF BIAS.
AND, HE WAS VERY TRANSPARENT
ABOUT IT ON TV AND ON BOOKS.
YOU ARE BEING SOLD A BILL OF
GOODS HERE THAT, THIS IS NEW
REVELATION.
IT WAS ANYTHING BUT NEW.
>> Tucker: THIS WAS HIS WHOLE
STORY.
THIS WAS -- HE BRAGGED ABOUT IT
ENDLESSLY.
ONCE WAS LOST AND NOW I'M FOUND.
DID YOU HEAR ANYBODY COVERING
THIS PAUSE FOR A MOMENT TO SAY,
IT'S A LITTLE WEIRD THAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT PRIVATE FINANCIAL
INFORMATION THAT IS SUPPOSED TO
BE PROPRIETARY?
NO ONE IS SUPPOSED TO HAVE THIS
INFORMATION.
DID ANYONE SAY THAT?
>> NO, NO ONE DOES.
I REMEMBER I WAS ON YOUR SHOW
AND WE TALKED ABOUT THE ACCESS
HOLLYWOOD TAPE.
THERE WAS A CONTENT OF IT BUT
THEN THERE WAS ANOTHER PART OF
THAT STORY WHICH WAS, HOW
EXACTLY DID THAT TAPE GET OUT OF
NBC AND INTO THE HANDS OF
"THE WASHINGTON POST" ," A MAJOR
ONE, THREE WEEKS BEFORE.
THAT'S THE FACT THAT WAS LEAKED
BY SOMEBODY, CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION AND GOT INTO THE
HANDS OF "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
AND OBVIOUSLY WILL SPREAD
EVERYWHERE.
AND BY THE WAY, I GET THAT
DON LEMON IS ON AT NIGHT AND
THERE ARE A LOT OF OPINIONS AT
NIGHT BUT HE IS STILL BUILT AS
AN ANCHOR.
FOR HIM TO TALK THAT WAY AN ACT
THAT WAY, I COULD NEVER PICTURE
BRET BAIER OR CHRIS WALLACE OR
DAVID MUIR EVER ACTING LIKE THAT
AND YOU WANT TO HEAR ABOUT
STRUGGLES.
SO IN CABLE NEWS, YOU HAVE TO
GET DOWN TO THE NUMBER 36 OUT OF
FOX AND NBC, NUMBER 36 TO FIND
THE HIGHEST RATED CNN SHOVEL.
THE OTHER ARE THE OTHER TWO
NETWORKS.
THEY ARE ALIENATING THEIR
VIEWERS BY ACTING LIKE CHILDREN
ON THE AIR, BUT THEY ARE DOING
IT AND THE RESULTS ARE HORRIBLE
FROM A BUSINESS PERSPECTIVE.